my family doesn't know about Jan that
she moved here for me and we are already
got engaged so I tell my family that
right now she is here so she want to
visit and she want to meet you
especially
recognize her yes yes
beautiful as well
that's all I was shocked to see Jen
because nobody comes home to meet
formally
especially from abroad
so
um do you live with your husband right
he's not here right now yeah oh
he is in Agra Agra okay
she's asking oh
why you are why you are here
um it's so uh I recently moved here
um I really I loved Jaipur it's such a
beautiful city and so yeah
[Music]
um
um so um Priyanka it's been two years
since she got married and you need to
find this one alive maybe find this one
a wife like how quickly are you looking
to
find wives for your sons because maybe I
can attend two weddings in your family
foreign
[Music]
have you found any potential wives for
Rishi yet
Jen just shut up your mouth don't make
this kind of question don't make things
worse
[Music]
thank you